[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 78 les invités voici les
titres nous recevons en plateau Émilie
Aquin chargée des Relations Entreprises
de l'école de la deuxième chance elle
nous expliquera pourquoi l'aide des
entreprises du territoire est important
pour le bon fonctionnement de l'école le
vélodrome national de 50 ans neline
accueil du hand le 25 mars prochain Ici
Paris club de D1 délocalise pour la
première fois de son histoire un match à
domicile dans l'enceinte ivelinoise pour
affronter Brest objectif battre le
record d'affluence pour un match de
première division qui est actuellement
de 5000
spectateurs Émilie Hin chargée des
relations en entreprise de l'école de la
deuxeme chance est avec nous ce soir sur
le plateau nous allons voir avec vous
pourquoi l'aide des entreprises du
territoire est important pour le bon
fonctionnement de l'école bonsoir madame
Aquin bonsoir alors déjà présentez-nous
l'école de la deuxè chance oui l'école
de la deuxè chance est un dispositif qui
accueille des jeunes âgés de 18 à 25 ans
pour qu' la rencontre avec l'école n'a
pas fonctionné et à travers un parcours
individualisé nous les aidons à accéder
à un emploi ou une formation qu'ils ont
choisi ils ont plusieurs activités au
sein de cette école voilà plusieurs
plusieurs cours donc ça va du français
ma rotique à des matières totalement
liées au projets professionnels ou
encore des matières comme la citoyenneté
la santé enfin tout tout ce qui leur
semble utile pour accéder à leur emploi
ou une formation on peut dire que les le
don des des entreprises un besoin vital
pour vous oui totalement ce budget de la
taxe d'apprentissage représente pour
nous 10 à 15 % 10 à 20 % pardon du
budget de l'école et il nous permet
effectivement de de bien fonctionner
alors pour que les patrons comprennent
ceux qui nous regardent il contribuent à
quoi exactement cet argent il sert à
quoi alors il sert au fonctionnement
général de l'école mais aussi à
permettre aux formateurs de d'élaborer
des projets que ce soit des projets
sportifs culturels citoyens on travaille
beaucoup la pédagogie par projet et et
ce budget cet argent voilà nous permet
de développer des des projets qui
coûteraient qui coûterait un peu à
l'école et qui nous sert voilà donc plus
les entreprises versent cette taxe à
l'école de la deuxème chance evveline et
plus les jeunes peuvent participer à des
projets et ces patrons ils peuvent le
donner à tout moment il y a une date
butoire expliquez-nous alors c'est on
est en pleine justement collègue de la
taxe
d'apprentissage la bonne question
d'accord merci et les entreprises ont
jusqu'au 28 février pour attribuer cette
taxe d'apprentissage c'est compliqué
pour avoir à chaque fois chaque année
c'est un combat pour c'est un combat
c'est un combat au quotidien c'est aussi
les entreprises qui nous font confiance
en accueillant not no stagiaires tout au
long de l'année qui savent à quoi
servent à quoi sert notre centre de
formation et puis voilà ça se fait ça se
fait automatiquement ell nous font
confiance elles savent comment on
travaille donc mais pour celles qui ne
nous connaissent pas voilà on demande
juste à se faire connaître sur le
territoire et à prouver que nos
stagiaires peuvent faire du très bon
travail et bien pour celles qui vous
connaissent pas on va les aider à se
rapprocher de vous euh les entreprises
qui ont déjà donné c'est quoi les les
retours qui font ils voi ses activités
ils sont contents il qu'est-ce qu'ils en
disent oui la plupart des stagiaires qui
trouvent un emploi sont suite à des
stages qu'ils ont effectué au sein des
entreprises on a de plus en plus
d'entreprises partenaires euh qui
accueillent des stagiaires mais qui
participent aussi à des actions comme
des jobs d'ting des préparations aux
entretiens de recrutement ou qui font
simplement visiter leurs entreprises
pour montrer les différents métiers qui
peuvent exister à nos stagiaires il y a
quoi comme type de filière qu'on peut
retrouver pour c'est totalement varié
voilà c'est tout types de métier c'est
on s'adapte au projet du du jeune c'est
lui qui arrive l'idée c'est vraiment
l'accès à un premier métier choisi donc
il arrive avec son projet nous on
l'accompagne on individualise suivant
suivant ses besoins je sais que des fois
le le stage peut faire peur à certains
patrons qu'est-ce que vous diriez de ces
jeunes qui sont à l'école de la deuxième
chance ça se passe bien les stages vous
les accompagnez vous êtes là avec eux
oui alors c'est déjà ce sont des jeunes
qui ont choisi eux-mêmes de venir faire
cette formation qui ont vraiment envie
de s'en sortir donc donc voilà les
stages leur permettent de découvrir des
métiers qui leur sont méconnus et puis
de voir si c'est réellement leur projet
ou pas et puis si ce n'est pas leur
projet de s'orienter sur un autre métier
donc les stage se passe effectivement
bien donc voilà plus on a d'entreprise
partenaire et meilleur meilleur est le
projet et le parcours pour le jeunees et
les résultats au final vous avez un bon
pourcentage de réussite oui on a de
tiers des jeunes qui sortent en emploi
ou en formation donc oui les résultats
sont sont assez bons et eux en stage ça
se passe comment quels sont les retours
qu' vont fond ces jeunesl ils sont très
contents enfin il y a de tout
forcément mais voilà ils sont sont
contents de pouvoir se confronter à la
réalité du métier au monde du travail et
puis d'être reconnu par par les
employeurs allez là c'est votre moment
dites-moi vous avez la caméra vous
comment vous pouvez vous attirer ces
entreprises qu'est-ce que vous allez
leur dire là c'est votre moment euh
faites confiance à nos jeunes tout
simplement voilà ils sont vraiment bien
bien accompagné bien soutenu par par
tous les formateurs et toutes les
équipes et puis les formateurs sont
vraiment là au quotidien s'il y a besoin
avec les tuteurs en stage donc voilà
faites-nous confiance et et puis
contactez-nous pour accueillir nos
stagiares et pour finir il faut vous
contacter où vous il y a que trois
écoles sur le département donc il y en a
une à mananville une au Mureau et une
autre à 550 an en Eveline donc voilà
vous avez le site internet ou le
Facebook ou le Twitter pour connaître
l'actualité de l'école et bien je vous
remerci madame aka merci le vélodrome
national de 50 ans ieline accueille du
handball le 25 mars prochain pour la
première fois de son histoire Ici Paris
club de D1 va délocaliser un match à
domicile dans l'enceinte ivlinoise pour
affronter Brest objectif battre le
record d'affluence pour un match de
première Divion vision qui est
actuellement de 5000 spectateurs écoutez
le président du club d'Ici Paris alors
je suis avec Jean-Marie CIFRE le
président d'Ici Paris alors nous venons
juste de sortir de la conférence de
presse qui a annoncé le gros match entre
Ici Paris et Brest alors Jean-Marie
est-ce que vous êtes impatient de jouer
ce gros match au Vélodrome national de 5
living qui se trouve juste derrière nous
oui impatient impatient parce que pour
nous et pour le Vélodrome c'est une
première avec un gros Chalon
de remplissage et puis de mettre une
salle de hbal dans ce dans ce vélodrome
donc oui très impatient et Hâ d'y être
d'autant que ce match contre Brest va
être relativement déterminant pour la
suite du championnat déterminant vous
êtes premier execo est-ce que le
championnat se déroulera finalement ici
la finale du championnat se déroulera
ici alors non parce que nous sommes en
formule de play-off championnat saison
régulière plus play-off donc en revanche
le résultat de la saison régulière a de
fortes chances de se oulé ici oui et
comment se sont passés les tractations
pour organiser ce ce match est-ce que
c'est un travail de longue haleine oui
ça fait longtemps que Patric Chea
président du comité de du territoire de
du handbal nous demande de venir jouer
un match sur son territoire et et et on
a rencontré les gens du Vélodrome on a
rencontré Patrick cheable les élus et
cetera et et on s'est tous mis d'accord
pour pour venir faire cet événement vous
étiez enthousiaste au début rétissent
peut-être de jouer dans une si grande
salle
euh pas réticent du tout euh inquiet
inquiet de de de mettre une salle de
handbal dans une salle comme celle-là
parce que c'est une c'est une topologie
un petit peu atypique euh mais mais au
fur à mesure on avancé dans les
discussions on s'est dit on va relever
le challenge on est un club qui se
délocalise de temps en temps en
Île-de-France on aime bien Leser jouer
des matchs en dehors de notre territoire
de prédilection qui qui sont etinau et
puis le Stade Pierre de Coubertin dans à
Paris mais mais donc on avait très envie
de venir jouer dans le dans le 78 et
dans le 78 dans une salle comme ça c'est
effectivement très excitant et le timing
est idéal il arrive juste après les
Championnats du Monde remportés par la
France oui alors on va pas trop se
mettre la pression quand même mais
effectivement le timing est idéal mais
nous le le le les matchs c'est toutes
les semaines donc toutes les semaine on
a des des matchs à enjeu donc c'est on
est habitué à ça là quand on regarde le
vélodrome justement il y a une vous
disiez un système un peu atypique au
niveau au niveau des places est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on peut remplir cette
salle
ah je pense on va pas se mettre ce cette
pression et ce challenge de remplir
absolument toutes les places mais mais
derrière la tête on a quand même envie
de de réussir avec les collectivités les
scolaires les les entreprises du secteur
donc on va travailler tout ça on a déjà
commencé on va continuer de de
travailler pour faire venir le plus de
monde possible alors le tarif pour les
50 chinois est à 5 € c'est une bonne
chose de démocratiser ce match de le
rendre accessible à tous ah oui oui mais
nous notre objectif est de de faire
connaître notre discipline alors le
handbal est connu le handbal féminin est
encore un peu méconnu par rapport au
handbal garçon et c'est pourtant un
sport extraordinaire et quand le public
va voir ses joueuses jouer à ce
niveau-là l'engagement l'esprit d'équipe
le respect tout toutes les valeurs qui
que nous portons dans ce sport je pense
qu'on va on va conquérire ce ce public
sans sans aucun doute et au niveau de
l'effectif également ici Paris est
peut-être la meilleure équipe du
championnat il y a des Norvégiennes
notamment qui jouent dans dans votre
équipe est-ce qu'on aura du spectacle
ici à du spectacle sans aucun doute on
va avoir deux grandes équipes puisque
Brest a une très grosse équipe également
avec une gardienne de but international
plusieurs joueuses
internationales nous aussi on a pas mal
de joueis internationales dont les
Norvégiennes récemment champon d'Europe
notamment la gardienne de but et la
notre demi ofal qui est qui est une des
meilleures joueuses du monde donc il va
y avoir du spectacle et du grand
spectacle ça va être un match très dur
d'autant que nous avons perdu au match
allé et nous avons une revanche à
prendre au match retour il reste à peu
près un mois et demi avant le début de
l'épreuve enfin de de ce match est-ce
que il y a du stress est-ce qu'il y a
l'appréhension ou est-ce que justement
c'est un stress positif non il y a pas
d'appréhension c'est bien que on vienne
voir la salle c'est bien que les joueur
viennent s'approprie un peu le lieu
elles sont pas toutes là mais mais mais
elles vont venir euh c'est pas il y a
pas de stress particulier il y a il y a
il y a une certaine impatience quand
même dernière dernière question
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez que les gens
retiennent de de ce match de cet
événement qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
qu'il retiennent euh la capacité
d'organiser un match de handball de très
haut niveau dans une enceinte comme
celle-là et je pense que si on réussi
cet objectif ça sera un Paris gagné pour
tout le monde ici la collectivité le le
l'rome et le club merci beaucoup
Jean-Marie j' pris merci c'est la fin de
ce 78 les invités bonne soirée à
[Musique]
tous